hi the uh
i was thinking you know we we wake up
each day and
we perhaps have different thoughts
perhaps we're feeling high hello
today i was thinking back about uh
my my journey my aikido journey
and uh
not everybody can afford to travel but i
was
fortunate enough i started when i was 23
and this is really just a story about
me my books cytosensing
and some of you perhaps switch off early
and others will be interested to listen
the reason i'm making this film today is
because
i've sold a few hundred
of these books now and my first book
this is my first book
and i was talked into oh tell a bit
about yourself
and i wanted to really just make a
technical manual
but uh i was encouraged so well tell
people how you arrived
so i done that and i arrived at aikido
not really wanting to do a martial art
at all
anyhow i did and those of you with my
book will
will know my full way i got into it
but more importantly i wanted to write
this book
and make it the first book that i know
of that's in the world
uh showing you how many styles of aikido
do
the same technique but the techniques
are being done
incorrect as far as security as a
martial art
so if you wanted to pin someone down
keep them there with as little effort as
possible
on your behalf
uh there's secure ways of doing the
technique
it'll be exactly the same technique as
anybody else does in any other style of
aikido
and there's numerous amounts of styles
depending on the teacher
and how they see the technique to be
done
so i wanted to put
right what i'd been taught when i met
cytoscency
and i and i've said this before
but that when i met him
i thought i had really good aikido but
it was crap it was absolutely rubbish
once i
was up against his personal
deshi his personal students that lived
with him in iwama
and they would go there for that's
months some years
and they were like trying to move the
biggest boulder
that had ever arrived for you to try and
pick up you know
i remember being gripped in the wrist
and beads of sweat pouring out of my
head because as i went to move the shock
of not being able to move big hands
strong body young
i'd been doing 10 years of aikido i was
a knee down
i'd been following cytosensei before on
films
and with his books i bought them i think
around about set 1975
they came out in 73 over
a period so i thought i was following
him
and i kept this to myself i didn't want
to tell the people
in the organization i was at whereas
they might not like me following a
another master so i used to keep to
myself
play the films the old cine films at
home
uh when the wife used to go out i used
to get the
films out play them and then
if it was ken or joe things you could do
on your own
you can do taijitsu i found out after
you know a few years on of course you
can what they call
shadow box you can you can pretend
you've got a
partner and but
but more importantly i used to do the i
used to have sliding double doors
and i would have the projector facing
opposite the doors so i could still have
it on
while i'm outside in the garden in the
dark
watching the cine film and then i'd
quickly run in
wind it back and watch saito sensei do
it backwards
and now looking back on it even though i
was an adult
i had a mind of a child because i
was convinced when winding the film
backwards
cytosins he was actually doing it
perfectly backwards
and then i would wind it forwards and
this
took me to another dimension where i
used to just
play a part let's say i i was doing a
joe submeri
and how he was and i would watch it
i'd wind it back and i'd watch him
intensely to see if he's doing the same
things
of course it's a film isn't it how
stupid am i
but at that point in time i wanted to
get it correct
so much and i was only a q grade then
when i
first had these films i started in 1973
so 75 when i got the books it wasn't
um you know i might have been orange
bell or something
so i was a young
ego driven aikidoka that
you know i thought i'd be the best
eventually and you know
i wanted to train so i would go outside
do some joe work or something
you know come back in wind it back as i
say
look at it again and go out there so
what i started doing
was i just put the book down
i would i would get the the joe and i
would
you know turn it above my head perhaps
and then i would think of how
i would do it backwards and i would keep
going like this
like this and i became the film
and this is how i personally learned
i was saying to my jane jane my partner
this morning we were doing yoga together
we tried to do yoga every morning
together
before the day it was really starts
and i was telling her that um
me being dyslexic the way i do things
is i do it and i have to keep repeating
it and repeating it and repeating it
it's a little bit like what in my days
at school
i don't think maybe do it now but my
days in school
we had a big a4 pad
and when we were naughty boys
um we had to write lines
i will not do this again i will not do
this
and and the teacher would say do a
hundred lines saying that you will
not throw chalk across the room again or
something like that
or whatever it was and i was always
doing lines
my writing's terrible today so it didn't
improve that
but it's a bit like writing lines you
know
you're you know pick the jar up ski
how did how would you go back because if
you
pick it up nicely and you do all the
right things and you ski nicely
and then you forget the path backwards
it becomes untidy and that's how i saw
my aikido path if i couldn't
undo what i'd just done in exactly the
same
path then to me
i was being shoddy i wasn't being
correct and perfect with all this
knowledge with all this thinking with
all these perfectionists
that i was doing 10 years on
i meet cytosensei in new zealand for the
first time
and i was absolute crap i might not have
been crap
he was really amazed that somebody would
travel across the world to just see him
he just he thought well he's just a man
why would anybody travel so really this
story brings me on
to one particular
time but i i was following him
but twice a year somewhere in the world
i had to see him it's like an adrenaline
rush
i had to get my fix if i didn't do it
i felt as if my kid i was falling apart
was i starting to make up techniques was
i starting to have
thoughts of my own that i shouldn't have
because when i
meet him again i'll be totally wrong
just jumping back a moment about the
film and how i thought the mind of a
child
so i done the first book and i wanted it
to be
really technical to show the small
changes not the big changes but if you
put your hand on the back of somebody's
head
in kaitenagi and you put it near the
neck
and you've got their arm and you throw
them
for this against somebody who decides to
resist
not the perfect uk the per the uk who
wants
who's got also an ego and he wants to or
she wants to fight back
um i never found it with ladies i must
know
perhaps it's only the men who have got
these big egos
anyhow if you and kaitenaggi you've got
your hand
near the neck here
or here even you will need strength
if you put your hand here on the crown
of the head
just here your hand will slip off
if you try to use uh strength
but if you've got the arm and the crown
of the head here
it's like a it's like a small
compression
the arm is pressing
and the head is pressing it's like a
triangular sandwich
from the crown of the head to the angle
of the arm
you perhaps can see this but it's a it's
a triangle and i could always
as we know all triangular circular
and square so
i wanted to make this book only
technical
but the feedback i've got over the years
is how much people have enjoyed
listening to my story
of how i got into aikido and they
all find it fascinating very rarely do i
get anybody talk about
the technical so this led me to make
a second book
i thought once you get the technical
they're not asking about the technique
so if they're not asking the technical
they're just interested in my story
perhaps i should tell i should think
about you know this second book
the second book i'll just take a bit to
the
camera but keeping the mind of a child
and this led me to think back of when i
had this notion that cytosensei
was doing the weapons perfectly forward
and then he would do them perfectly
backwards
and i realized that only a child thinks
like that
you know a child sees clear
thinking if you say to a seven-year-old
child or five-year-old child come on
we've got to go
we've got five minutes they don't know
what five minutes is they don't they're
not run on time
their world's not like an adult
so this second book was developed
really for those who trans
rest through the technical stages
and i wanted to work on the person
you know who is this person that thinks
like this who is this person that's
travelled the world
it's inside psychosensory in every
continent there is on the globe
this person is you
it's me we actually have
even though we're very individual we
have
very similar desires when it comes to
what we would like out of life
so the second book goes into
what i believe i've done
and you should do to
improve your aikido by improving
yourself
you will improve your iq techniques will
only get you so far and then they get
stuck
improve yourself the way you think the
way you
criticize the way you judge the way you
can become a piece
then you'll find that the mat time is
much more precious
the techniques start working better you
start
looking at the aikido that i believe
is where aikido starts not
at the beginning where we wanted to do
the perfect sheer naggy or
you know have great fun throwing people
in go to guys
and how high could you get your friend
and and how much would you resist them
or
try and be as good as them
so one day
there i was going off to see saito
scentsy across the world
and i was going to the usa new jersey
and he would do what he called a book
signing
and i hadn't thought about this this is
perhaps well i was a little bit gullible
there was a long cure people and he was
sitting in this
very like this very small closet
and people would come in he would sign
their
book one of his books one of his five
volumes this is in the early days
before stamping made the new set
so this was the five volumes they would
have one be very proud
but i thought in my head why would i go
all the way to america
and carry yes quite a heavy book but
carry a book when i'm actually going to
see the person
to be trained by him why would i need a
book of him i need the book when i get
back home
so i'm in this row and i'm the only per
because i wanted just to be in his
presence really
you know on the mat he's up there you're
down there
it's like an elephant and a flea that's
a bad way of putting it so
i'm in this queue everybody's getting
that book out and he's got his bio
pen and ball point and he's just signing
it
stamping here and uh yeah with a
normal rubber stamp and an ink pad don't
sign set off they come out the cupboard
next one goes in
closet cupboard next one goes in same
thing's happening
and i get to him and i'd actually taken
this book
here that we've got here the book of
five rings
i'm not a great reader never have been
um and i was thinking that
i should read this book because at the
time
it was known as the book that every
japanese
doesn't matter whether they're martial
artists or not every japanese should
read the book of five rings
because it's character building now i
read this book
a nice sally book i had in my hand
so when it gets to my turn to go into
the
little closet there he sits i can still
see him today he's amazing
isn't it he had his glasses on his black
glasses
and he's there and he looks at me goes
ah tony
he was always so delighted to see me
that
um i got a bit choked sorry
sorry
anyhow i i i only had this book
he doesn't understand english i don't
understand japanese
so i said sensei and i showed him the
book
he opens it he puts the biro
and the impact to one side he
and he gets out of his case
but i didn't know he had he gets his
calligraphy brush
and a different stamp
his own personal stamp chalk
and he signs the book
and here's a signature
he signs it he smiles
he always thought why would somebody
follow him around the world
well it's obvious isn't he's my master
and um anyhow the person behind me i
always remember
i s as i turned to come out
the row of faces that could see me
had the book and him with his
calligraphy
brush signing it they were beaming
because they you know not just the bio
pen
as i turned again and said no more
scentsy
he just puts his pen in the white he
puts his calligraphy brush away
and he's chuck special chop puts it back
in his little
little you know a pat side bag that
we would carry then and um
and then gets his bio and more or less
says next
and um you know silly things like that
have stayed with me
it's not so silly is it because uh what
a great honor
so this book and i shall keep
and i just wanted to really share that
story with you
so we'll all have special thoughts and
memories
it's sad because i do believe in trying
to save the planet
and perhaps we shouldn't travel so much
but you should go and try and do it
the most economical way you can but see
as many top teachers as you can
train with as many friendly people as
you can because
if they're other aikidoka they will be
friendly
they will greet you they will be nice to
you
advance your aikido and friendship
because when you get to the journey that
i've been on to be able to talk to you
what would you have to look back on what
memories would you have
do as much as you can
your life will be full and rich
don't just train in the dojo and have a
good time
then go back to your normal everyday
week
make it a life of ambition
and a life of pleasure do this
and you will know that you've had
something worthwhile
in life i found aikido
i went on to tai chi china
blended that with my kido it helps
improve my techniques
i do yoga most days because i want to
keep my body
in good shape because my head doesn't
think that i'm old my head thinks that
i'm me i'm tony
just because i can't do quite what i
used to when i was young
doesn't mean to say i can't in my mind
so please hope you've enjoyed it
and i'll see by how many
views it gets and how long the duration
is
thank you for listening